Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Je vous invite à fermer les yeux.
Laissez les paupières tout doucement
se déposer, se fermer.
Je propose d’essayer de ressentir
que vous êtes réellement assis.
Vous sentez bien
vos fesses sur le fauteuil,
vos pieds sur le sol.
Ce contact intime avec
ce qui vous soutient à cet instant.
Puis, doucement, lorsque vous êtes prêts,
portez votre attention
sur votre respiration.
Notez simplement
comment est votre souffle.
Juste pour vous.
Ce souffle unique.
Vivant.
Vous pouvez sentir
le mouvement d’expansion à l’inspiration,
de contraction à l’expiration.
Sentir cet espace, là,
qui s’ouvre petit à petit.
Peut-être un espace de calme,
de tranquillité. Juste en vous.
Et voir que c’est la vie qui est là.
La vie, qui fait que
cette respiration existe.
Que cet air circule
partout, en vous et à l’extérieur de vous.
Quand c’est bon pour vous,
vous pouvez tout doucement
inviter vos paupières à se rouvrir.
Je voudrais vous remercier.
Je dois vous remercier
d’être avec vous ce soir.
De m’accueillir chez vous.
Qu’on soit ensemble dans cette intimité
du silence qu’on vient de partager.
Ce n’est pas souvent
qu’on s’offre ce silence.
Ce n’est pas souvent qu’on fait silence.
Ce n’est pas souvent qu’on s’autorise
et qu’on s’offre ce cadeau
de sentir la vie.
De la sentir dans le présent, juste là.
Vous voyez ? À cet instant,
je me dis, mais…
c’est fou ! J’ai préparé pendant
des semaines cette conférence.
J’ai juste un petit quart d’heure
et je suis tendu vers
(Geste de surprise)
Qu’est-ce que je vais bien pouvoir dire ?
Comment ça va se passer ?
J’aimerais que ça se passe comme ça,
que vous compreniez ce que je raconte.
J’aimerais que vous repartiez avec
une idée nourrissante et inspirante
pour votre présent de demain.
Puis, dans l’instant,
je suis très tendu, agité.
Les mots ne viennent pas
tout à fait comme j’ai prévu.
Il y a cette tension très forte, là,
entre ce que je désire et
ce qui est juste maintenant.
Je vois bien que ce qui est
juste maintenant
m’empêche d’aller vers mon désir.
En fait, la question que j’ai envie
de partager avec vous ce soir, c’est :
est-ce qu’on peut désirer le futur
si on n’arrive pas à aimer
ce qui se passe au présent ?
Est-ce qu’on peut désirer le futur
si on n’aime pas le présent ?
Si on rejette le présent.
Je voudrais vous partager un secret.
Bon, on est un peu
nombreux pour un secret.
Donc, vous le garderez avec vous.
Juste pour vous, ne le répétez pas.
Mais, ce n’est pas si drôle que ça.
Il y a une dizaine d'années, j'étais à
Armentières, à l'hôpital psychiatrique.
J'étais en dépression.
Et, quatre fois pendant
les six mois où j’étais à l’hôpital,
j’ai tenté de mettre fin à mes jours.
Je me souviens d’un soir,
je ne sais plus exactement la date.
Les infirmières étaient parties.
J’étais seul dans ma chambre
et je me suis dit :
Stéphane, c’est le moment.
C’est fini.
J’ai décidé de le faire,
j’ai patiemment enroulé mes draps,
accroché mes draps à la fenêtre
avec un nœud que j’avais fait
et je savais que c’était maintenant.
Je me suis assis
sur mon lit en me disant :
offre-toi une minute
pour ton dernier souffle.
Je me suis assis et j'ai fait exactement
ce que nous venons de faire ensemble.
J’ai pris le temps d’être là
en me disant
de toutes façons, c’est le dernier.
Autant en profiter.
Puis, au bout d’un petit moment,
j’ai commencé à savourer.
Je me suis dit : tiens,
c’est quand même plutôt pas mal !
C'est quand même agréable.
Je respire, je sens la vie.
Et si je continuais encore un peu ?
Cette méditation
que je pratique tout le temps
pas parce que tous les jours
j’ai envie de me suicider mais (Rire)
parce que ça me fait du bien au quotidien.
Elle m’a enseigné quelque chose
que je voudrais partager.
C’est ce que j’ai réussi
dans cette réalité, dans ce chaos
à prendre soin de moi.
J’ai réussi à aimer le présent.
Cette petite fissure de lumière
qui perçait le mur noir de mon désespoir.
En l’aimant un peu,
je me suis sauvé la vie quatre fois.
Exactement de la même manière.
J'ai pas recommencé depuis.
Ça me fait penser à
un souvenir très touchant.
J’ai rencontré Marcel.
Marcel est une personne âgée
qui est décédée maintenant,
une personne âgée que j’allais
visiter régulièrement à l’hôpital.
Je l’aimais beaucoup. On s’appréciait
beaucoup. Son regard était
bleu clair, pétillant !
Marcel, un jour, je suis allé
le voir dans sa chambre.
Il m’a accueilli avec :
« Stéphane, j’ai peur de mourir. »
Je me suis senti absolument désemparé.
Je ne savais pas du tout quoi faire.
Alors j’ai essayé de le rassurer :
« Mais Marcel, franchement,
tes examens sont bons,
on vient de me le dire.
T’es en bonne santé, on vient de me
le dire. Alors, de quoi t’as peur ? »
C’était pas tout à fait la bonne stratégie
parce que ce qu’il s’est passé,
c’est qu’il a plissé ses yeux encore plus.
Il a fermé son regard, il s’est contracté
et il n’a plus rien dit.
Alors, j’ai choisi une autre stratégie,
je me suis dit :
je vais m’assoir à côté de lui,
puis je vais le regarder avec un air
très compassionné et attendre.
Je l’ai fait et au bout d’un
certain nombre de minutes,
je ne sais plus exactement
combien de temps,
son regard s’est de nouveau éclairé
et il m’a remercié
en me disant : « Tu viens de me faire
l’un des plus beaux cadeaux de ma vie. »
Marcel avait 96 ans.
« Tu vois, Stéphane, je ne sais pas
si je vais mourir dans trois minutes,
trois heures, trois jours,
trois mois, j’en ai aucune idée.
Mais, ce que je viens de voir,
c’est que tu m’as offert une fenêtre.
Tu m’as offert un nouvel espace
dans lequel je pouvais sentir
qu’il y avait peut-être
quelque chose encore à désirer. »
Marcel est décédé à 99 ans,
trois ans après.
Ce qui m’a touché, en fait,
c’est qu’il me parlait d’espérance.
Il me parlait de : « J’ai trouvé dans
le présent de quoi espérer l’avenir.
J'ai trouvé dans le présent la force,
l'élan, le mouvement pour y aller.
Je ne sais pas de quoi sera fait demain,
mais, ce n’est pas grave, j’y vais.
En confiance ! »
C’est exactement cette confiance
qu’on retrouve dans les lotus.
J’ai vécu trois ans au Cambodge
et j’étais fasciné à chaque fois
que je sortais dans la campagne
par ces petites taches roses
qui constellaient la campagne.
C’était les mares dans lesquelles
poussaient des lotus.
Vous voyez comment
cette fleur de lotus est magnifique.
Elle est vénérée, elle est respectée
elle est offerte dans les temples.
Mais un jour, je me suis demandé
comment ça peut pousser
dans une eau aussi saumâtre
et dans une boue aussi profonde.
Alors, je suis allé demander.
Tout le monde m’a ri au nez.
Au Cambodge, on se préoccupe pas
de comment poussent les lotus.
On profite de la joie d'avoir des fleurs.
Moi, je me demandais
comment ça pousse.
J'étais un bon Occidental
dans un pays d'Asie.
Donc on m'a ri au nez.
Et un jour, j’ai rencontré
un chef de village
qui me dit : « En fait,
tout commence par une graine. »
J’ai dit merci.
J’imaginais qu’effectivement, ça pouvait
bien commencer par une graine.
« Oui, et tu vois, la graine pousse,
puis, elle fait une fleur. »
Ok. Très bien.
Mais, si je regarde bien.
où va la graine ?
Elle traverse une eau saumâtre.
Elle tombe dans la boue.
Elle germe en quatre jours,
et en une semaine, vous avez une fleur.
Je me dis : Wow,
quel enseignement de la nature !
Quel enseignement qui me dit,
fais confiance au processus de la vie !
Quoi qu’il arrive, le futur est bon.
Le futur peut te donner le meilleur.
Le futur peut te laisser éclore
toi-même.
Beau dans ce futur et ton mouvement
même, amènera un futur magnifique.
Faire confiance à la vie.
Et puis,
je vous ai invité à prendre
soin de vous, indirectement.
C’était un peu
une façon de vous dire que
dans mes moments tragiques, j’avais un…
une folle envie de savourer
ce qui était en train de se passer
de prendre soin de moi dans ce moment-là.
Marcel, j’ai pris soin de lui
et nous avons pris soin de nous
tous les deux.
On fait confiance à la vie.
Alors, que nous reste-t-il encore ?
Peut être, de prendre soin du monde.
J’aimerais vous proposer un petit exercice
sur ce thème de :
« prendre soin du monde ».
Un beau monde.
Un monde dont on rêve.
Alors si ça vous va,
je vous propose de nouveau
de fermer les yeux.
Prenez le temps de fermer les yeux
et d’amener votre attention
un peu comme si…
Souvent, on a le regard
à l’extérieur de nous-même.
Là, ma proposition, c’est de tourner
le regard vers vous-même.
Prenez ce temps.
Juste pour aller rencontrer
votre respiration.
Notez comment,
cette respiration va et vient.
Notez cet espace
qui s’ouvre, qui se referme.
Il n’y a rien à faire.
Rien du tout.
Notez comment la respiration est
sans doute assez tranquille à l’intérieur.
Et dans cette tranquillité,
je vous propose
de laisser émerger une question
et d’accueillir toutes les réponses.
Sans les classer,
sans les trier, sans les rejeter.
La question, c’est :
à quoi je rêve
pour le monde de demain ?
Laissez émerger toutes les réponses
comme un feu d’artifice
où tout jaillit dans le ciel noir.
À quoi je rêve
pour le monde de demain ?
Tout doucement, lorsque vous êtes prêts,
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux.
Et ce que je vous propose,
c’est qu’une fois que
vous avez les yeux ouverts,
de tourner votre regard vers
votre voisin ou votre voisine
et de partager vos réponses.
Vous avez une minute.
(Chuchotements)
Alors, il y a beaucoup de réponses.
Ce que je vous propose maintenant,
c’est de revenir tout doucement
au silence.
Voilà. Prenez le temps de
terminer votre phrase quand même !
De revenir tout doucement au silence.
Voilà.
À quoi je rêve pour le monde de demain ?
Quelle belle question, quand même !
C’est bien la question
des futurs désirables.
C’est bien cette question-là.
Je vais vous partager mon rêve.
Je voudrais un monde
où personne n’ait peur de vivre.
Je voudrais un monde où chacun ait
l’élan de prendre soin de lui.
Parce que je sais
de ma pratique méditative,
de son enseignement depuis des années,
que quand on commence
à prendre soin de soi,
on est capable de transmettre, de le faire
rayonner aux autres et au monde.
Prendre soin de soi, des autres,
de la vie et du monde.
Je voudrais qu’on puisse s’engager
dans un monde
plus apaisé, plus bienveillant
plus joyeux, plus uni aussi.
Et je voudrais
que tous, ici ce soir,
nous puissions aimer le présent,
que nous puissions désirer le futur,
et que nous puissions
rendre ce futur désirable.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)